so two out hit by aguilar
four straight balls to adam duvall and
here is jesus sanchez
and a ground ball backhanded by sosa a
nice play
the milan strand a pair
no damage done
and the criticals coming up in the home
half of the first no score
[Applause]
he's also a hard guy to string three or
four hits together against
going again swinging a miss throw from
leone is in time
strike him out throw him out double play
well the strikeout the big part of this
quick release by sandy and you're right
though a bit of a high throw
but on the mark nice job by birdie
bringing the
tag down and holding on to the baseball
brown ball
verde over there on the shift
whoa
aguilar was off the bag according to
first base umpire ryan attitude aguilar
says no way
now we'll see if the marlins take a look
at it or not and the marlins will in
fact challenge
yeah i i just like how jesus waves off
the first base umpire after he doesn't
like the call of safe he's like no no
let's go to the headphones
well let's take a look it looks like he
held the back the entire time to me
there's no reason to believe that he
even came off the back i believe that
when he went to the highest point to
catch the baseball he's still on right
there
[Music]
all right now we're going to break
sosa retired
marlins need traffic they didn't have a
lot of it last night just one for two
with runners in scoring position and
four left on base all night
they left two on in the first and two on
in the second they've already left four
on base marte goes with the pitch and
that's lined into center field to base
hit carlson cuts it off marte is on his
way to third he'll stay right there and
the marlins have them on the corners
here in the third the ball gets away in
the middle of the diamond and aguilar
goes to second
[Applause]
heads up base running by aguilar and
they get two in scoring position on the
play
he had one yesterday where he came in
the ball beat him by because he'd come
in so far
very similar route he came in and then
realized that the ball was hit much
harder had to retreat just a bit misses
the cutoff man and
you know when do you see on a big league
field the ball kind of come to a rolling
stop near the mound
may not be getting the long starts but
it was one earned run or less for about
five straight duval left field drops in
a base hit in comes marty aguilar held
it third
and the throw
gets away uh from marinado and molina
had to come up and get that one and on
the back side of that play
duval gets to second did it again great
great base running this is exactly what
you want it's an easy read out of the
box for duval line drive base hit to
left he's reading all of the action in
front you can walk right into second
base
nice job stayed on the breaking ball
watch the throw from o'neal see how high
it is you're you're the runner at first
base nolan aronado's not cutting that
off and throwing it at you
young one for 17 with runners in scoring
position this year the 1-1 pitch ground
ball
the young backhands with time makes the
play
so the marlins pick up a run and a lead
but it could have been much worse
sosa fly ball right field near the line
duvall makes the catch almost over ran
it
we got a little dicey in the right field
corner
you've all got under control just before
making the catch center fielder's the
great athlete right the guys in left and
right
their job's tougher the ball it moves it
doesn't always stay straight like it
does in center field
you've all doing everything in his power
to get to the line find the wall and oh
by the way don't overrun the baseball
andrew miller
throwing in the saint louis bullpen
hit the third backhanded arenado slings
it to goldie for the out
30-0 for two with a walk
on one of those crazy plays but he would
work on
different things that other guys didn't
there's a strikeout and
that's number five for kim tonight
two balls and two strikes
102 pitches tonight for kim
finishes it
where the strikeout is sixth of the
night
and one run aloud
to take that through six
two and two the count and the next by
rogers
rondon his first pinch hit
base hit of the year and the cardinals
have their second hit tonight
the other was dylan carlson
and that was back in the fourth
[Applause]
the 2-2 pitch to dylan carlson
here it comes and they pick them off and
they throw it away maybe the break the
cardinals need
now the third standing up
the cardinals will get a runner at third
with one out
oh did they need this
sometimes you just need to be given a
gift and this is a big-time gift right
here
on the pick-off now can you cash that
gift in sitting there at third base
but just a bad throw by rogers
marlins have the infield in and there is
that strikeout a big one for rogers
his sixth and there are now two away
well the circle change has been his best
friend
it's the guy you want to see up in a
spot like this
goldschmidt is over two he is struck out
fly to center
the 2-2 pitch
goldschmidt base head into right he
comes through
on a 2-2 pitch a base hitting the right
with two outs here in the bottom of the
sixth and the cardinals have tied it
it's 1-1 goldie says no worries i got
this a change-up from roger shoots it
right through a wide open right side
a whole new ballgame and an energy and a
life that hasn't been in the ballpark
all evening
but none of the missed opportunities in
this ballgame matter right now
about what you do here
the one-two
[Applause]
center
[Applause]
wins it
he drives in both
schmidt tied it in the sixth and he wins
it in the bottom of the ninth
you didn't have to get to nolan
goldie said i'll take care of
walk off homer
and the cardinals have taken the first
two in this series a 98 mile an hour
fastball away by garcia goldie is ready
for it jumps all over it and that right
there
that might be the thing that the
cardinals needed the walk-off winner
some momentum some excitement a series
win already
what a game